but going on with hurricane Harvey
because it's closing in on the Texas
Gulf Coast and could hammer the area for
days the dangerous category 2 storm is
due to make landfall in less than 24
hours between Corpus Christi and Houston
it's not likely to move very far until
Tuesday
dropping huge amounts of rain the
National Weather Service says Harvey is
life-threatening and poses a grave risk
Harvey is already packing winds of more
than 100 miles an hour and is expected
to get even stronger today forecasters
predict up to 3 feet of rain in some
areas after harvey stalls out the storm
surge overnight could be up to 15 feet
along the coast millions of souls are in
Harvey's path including a team of
correspondents ready with the newest
information on Harvey
David beg no begins our coverage in
Corpus Christi Texas this morning David
good morning the rain bands are already
starting to move onshore but what we're
really feeling is the wind this morning
the lights are still on but when you
drive through Corpus Christi nobody is
on the road I got to tell you a lot of
people have decided to board up their
homes hunker down and stay others have
left but if you're still looking to get
supplies today it may be too late as
hurricane Harvey sets its sights on
Corpus Christi hotel consultant Jeff
DeLong is making people get out
hopefully it won't be that bad but it
looks like it's
looks like it's gonna be fun across
southern Texas grocery store shelves are
bare people are rushing to stock up on
last-minute supplies you gotta have your
spam and cans of chili tuna sandbags are
being piled up and businesses are
already boarded up hospitals worried
about power outages have begun
transporting critically ill babies from
the Texas coastline and moving to
Midland many people in Corpus Christi
are getting out taking the city up on an
offer to leave town for free
hundreds of people boarded school buses
headed for an evacuation center in San
Antonio along the coast thousands of
people are under mandatory evacuations
but not here in Corpus Christi I think
people are smart enough to make their
decisions and they don't need the
government telling them what to do
Mayor Joe bacome has decided not to
order people out why not put a mandatory
evacuation for those low-lying areas you
don't have any enforcement authority and
we just felt like that a lot of people
would rather stay here in their homes
the mayor knows the risks of severe
weather two years ago his
daughter-in-law and two grandchildren
died in a flash flood in Wimberley Texas
he says it's up to the people here to
make their own decision are you staying
or are you leaving my family there were
no warnings on the flash flood at
Wimberly I don't want that experience to
happen to anybody else the mayor made a
point to tell us look I could change my
mind and we could make it a mandatory
evacuation letter later today by the way
if you're still looking to get out of
Corpus Christi until 12:00 noon today
the city will offer those free bus rides
get on any city bus around town you'll
go to the receiving center they'll put
you on a school bus and take you to San
Antonio but that's only until 12 noon
today at that point everything shuts
down nor wow David thank you so much